>> Barrett:
Hi, my name is Ryan Barrett.
I'll be speaking at I/O.
So imagine
you're starting a startup
or an open source project,
and you're working with people
who live in
a bunch of different places.
Everyone lives
in a different place.
But say you couldn't
email with them
or IM or talk on the phone.
Say the only way you could
communicate with them
was flying to one of them,
you know,
and meet one on one.
You could never
get more than two of you
in the same place at a time.
So this is how
we have to think
when we design protocols
for managing data
and building products
that run across data centers.
It's no fun,
but we still need to do it,
because we need
our products to run
even if any data center
at any time
falls into the ocean,
or, more likely,
has a power outage
or has a fire.
So this is what my talk
is about.
How can you write a product
or develop a system
that runs in the face of
not only a single server
or a few servers,
but an entire data center
going down at any time?
We don't have any magic.
We do have a few people
who have invented protocols
that deal with
this kind of thing, though.
One of the most interesting
is Paxos.
It's what we call
a distributed
consensus protocol,
where without any single master,
you can have a bunch
of different entities--
data centers,
servers inside data centers,
agree on something.
So most people know
that you need
to replicate your data.
At a minimum for safety,
you need backups.
If you do
a write to one data center,
and it comes back,
and you immediately do a read
that gets routed
to another data center,
if that data hasn't replicated
from the original data center
to the other one,
you're kinda screwed, right?
So you either need
to block on it,
but you don't
wanna block too much
on too much replication,
because then every action
your user takes
takes forever.
So these kinds of trade-offs,
these kinds of tensions
are what makes this kind
of problem interesting.
I can't wait
to talk more about that
and share that with people
both inside and outside
the company,
so I look forward
to seeing you at I/O.